la science s'invite au sein de la
gendarmerie du cher avec de la physique
et de la chimie pour élucider crimes
délits et infractions
on a déjà une cellule en investigations
criminelles de six techniciens qui font
ça à temps plein et qui donc appuyé les
unités dans leurs investigations
judiciaires et on a également au niveau
du groupement une politique de formation
qui fait que dans chaque unité
on met en place des techniciens en
investigation criminelle de proximité
qui sont chargées des ventes de procéder
à ces prélèvements à ses relevés au plus
près des scènes d'infraction ça une
trace révélé aux colorants b y 40
exploitables spécialement formés aux
techniques d'investigation criminelle
les gendarmes en blouse blanche ont
leurs laboratoires c'est ce plateau
technique et scientifique qui fait
parler les traces et indices relevés sur
les scènes de crime
là on la voit là une eu des fois on la
voit pas forcément à l'oeil nu
donc on met on
longueur d'onde particulière la ses 415
nanomètres et je dois mettre des
lunettes jaunes avec un filtre jaune ce
qui fait que la lumière là moi je la
voie verte
vous la voyez bleus et l'emprunt jeu-là
wafo se fie aux récentes alors que vous
la verrez juste éclairé en ces enquêtes
scientifiques sont particulièrement
rigoureuses parce que ce sont aussi des
preuves irréfutables
la preuve scientifique c'est le pilier
central du procès pénal avant des aveux
suffisait pour condamner quelqu'un
maintenant ça ne suffit plus donc il
faut apporter la preuve est la preuve
scientifique
même si elle commence à être elles aussi
démontée par les défenses c'est quand
même ça qui va pouvoir permettre
aux juges de se faire une appréciation
sur ce qui s'est passé
popularisée dans la série télévisée le
véritable service d'investigation
criminelle de la gendarmerie de bourges
pourra être visitée pendant la fête de
la science